[Music]
what he does with the awp is unholy like
it should not be allowed
he's so nuts he's absolutely insane he's
at a whole other level than anyone any
other opera in north america right now
skadoodle and the awp it is hard to top
that
the skadoodle show is kicking off here
ladies and gentlemen
he's a threat oh my goodness
it was all too classic my
god there's that tired cliche that
assumes the quietest person in the room
is also the most dangerous and like
every cliche
its kernel of truth has become a soupy
mess that's lost all meaning
but on this rare occasion that saying
could not
be more real you know for me he goes
down as one of the best players north
america has ever produced the best offer
easily that north america has ever ever
produced they had gone for a force by
and they are going to be blasting
through onto b-side skadoodle guess what
gets two that's the bomb carrier down
gets inside for triple he has the angle
with the awp the molotov forcing
anyone away from swinging wide grabs the
second kill great and a third one
skadoodle what a recovery and hold all
four kills for skadoodle
looking to rush him down apex midair
it's a duck hunt finds the one gets the
second he's even got the setup for the
third
skadoodle he's a monster his name is
skadoodle
and this is his story
[Music]
tyler skadoodle latham was born on july
31 1993 in the quad cities area of iowa
i grew i grew up in like a small i
didn't grow up on a farm
not a farm not a farm uh
but kind of like a small uh area
uh not too high pop i lived with two of
my brothers
and my sister and mom and dad
introduced the video games at an early
age skadoodle played the typical titles
you'd expect from a kid growing up in
the late 90s
and early 2000s but by 2007 the
self-professed mama's boy with a
penchant for track and field and bmx
bikes
stumbled across alliance of valiant arms
aba was a free-to-play shooter that
gained a following in europe and
asia and it was on this title where
skadoodle quickly made a name for
himself
to defend they're pushing up
great
eventually skadoodle would join team
defcon and help them to win a trip to
south korea to compete in the ava world
cup
and it was there where skadoodle's
diabolical talent was put on display for
all to witness
at 17 years old skadoodle returned home
a champion
and spent the next two years focusing on
school while continuing to dabble with
ava
but his interest began to wane as the
prospect of college
grew near and around the same time a
little game called counter-strike
reigns supreme in the world of
competitive first-person shooters
it was tight before now scream is a big
job on his hands
he gets one onto instead he gets another
one that's three
screams spamming away neal doesn't get
the diffuse
technical
[Music]
and fluid as hell
[Music]
back before consistent updates and
patches became the norm
when a new game launched it was expected
that the community would shift to the
new product
but when counter-strike global offensive
launched in august of 2012
the cs community wasn't exactly stoked
at valve's latest iteration of the
beloved shooter
when i first started playing cs go i
didn't want to play because it was just
it was ran really bad
it was just terrible i didn't want to
play i think a lot of people felt that
way
but the opportunity that was given was
like something that you just can't like
not
take because at the time it was like a
slingshot straight to the top
of the league skadoodle decided to give
it a shot and joined hold mouse one
whose roster consisted of a ragtag group
of former cod players
combine a lull in the competitive scene
as players began to move from 1.6 and
source to go
with the team that scrimmed seven games
a night and it wasn't long before hmo
caught the attention
of team curse signing with the
organization in november of 2012.
yeah so skadoodle kind of cropped into
my
my awareness actually pretty early in
his cs career
um he was part of a team of players that
switched over all from other games a
couple cod players who were on this team
called old mouse one
and when i was when i was competing in
the early days of cs go
um and then they were able to kind of
catch you off guard and steamroll you
and scootal was really one of like kind
of the
star names on that team with the awp
juvenile trying to come in for supports
google pulls out the pistol and gets the
frag
two versus three the two card players
are left here in this situation
huge it's all up to adren now and
volcano two versus two
volcano just kind of chilling on cat
he's gonna flash for his teammate
adrienne
adrian is not going to try to make these
peaks here he's spotting out ninjas find
out everything
skadoodle catches the drink it's all
it's a volcano the clutch here
yeah he spots one ninja and he knows
that one has an off he's trying to win
this round but skadoodle just goes
hard with that but skadoodle had yet to
settle into a specific role
rotating from right floor to opera
depending on the situation
but once curse began to heat up a more
permanent decision
needed to be made well when i first
started playing csgo i actually didn't
want to be an offer
i just had no one on my team that wanted
to be an offer so i was like all right
well i used to play a va i used to be a
sniper so okay i'll
pick up the off no problem oh yeah dude
easy man that guy makes
a top three off in the world using the
op skadoodle displayed flashes of
brilliance that the team never truly
coalesced around
and by september of 2013 after a string
of disappointing results
curse released its roster skadoodle was
teamless and looking at other options
but an opportunity from one of the
competitive scenes biggest north
american
sponsors would have him reconsider my
plan was just to get
through generals in college just kind of
get through like
the general classes everyone needs to
take but
um halfway through like the college of
the
the generals that's when like um
i buy power swung around later that next
year into the
into the spring and so uh
that's when i just gave up classes and i
was just like i'm just gonna pursue this
joining i buy power skadoodle set
college aside and look to build a
championship caliber counter-strike
career
i buy power didn't miss a beat heading
into 2014
and signed counter-strike prodigy swag
and veteran tactician steele
before going on an absolute tear gun
fighting right there
does not matter they're going to push in
census is going to get those kills so
only one player left alive that's going
to be skadoodle
he's going to be fighting to try and
have this and he gets another kill right
there so skadoodle with the 2k
and can he get hiko he goes oh and he
gets hiko he clutches the round
one versus three census at 57 hp
skadoodle gets that kill on anger right
there nothing so very low now down to 15
it goes down
so now it's all up december it's center
what
yeah skadoodle is absolutely absolutely
absolutely on fire and this overtime he
already has
14 kills i buy power was a force to be
reckoned with in the n a
scene and skadoodle was quickly making a
name for himself as an opera with
cat-like reflexes and the ability to
clutch around in even the most
dire of situations we have skadoodle who
is
absolutely insane i'm more worried about
skadoodle man like yeah what he does
with the awp is unholy like it should
not be allowed basically he's on the
fast track to hell
so this having skadoodle and the awp it
is hard to top that
while they had little success against
top tier european teams
they dominated the domestic competition
and i by power were in a constant battle
against cloud9 for the title of na's
best team
now this particular lineup was a top two
n a team back when there really only
were two top
na teams which was cloud9 and bye bye
power i always thought they were the
better team
in terms of the pieces in terms of
international play in general it was
cloud nine
in terms of domestic play and the
potential to do more
hinted at by occasional international
results it was the either power guys
the team was on a roll and looked poised
for greatness
that is until august 20th 2014
where one match flipped the table on the
entire cs go scene
look at this they're actually doing a
strange buy here they're going for a
round two surprise bye
i gotta say the entries are looking a
little weak from either power along with
the strats i mean they're just doing
very basic things they're trying to just
fully attack these sites and
it's very unlike them that could have
been an easy 3k for him
they will take the b bomb site though
he's gonna try and get the flank off
he's gonna have two right there can they
line up for him
what is he doing why did he hesitate so
much doesn't matter has the cc gets one
gets taken down hayes was so very low
they lined up perfectly for him but for
some reason oh he says he wanted a knife
are they really just going to wait the
time out right now is this really
happening
oh skadoodle skadoodle why would
i don't understand the match meant
nothing to eye buy power
and they should have dominated netcode
guides the cs go community thought so as
well
and rumors of match fixing spread
quickly
behind the scenes esports journalist
richard lewis began looking into the
situation
i had the conversation the log which was
verified as genuine
uh from shazam saying the game was a
throw i had shazam basically saying i
will go on the record
and tell you everything uh you know in
exchange for
not being uh incriminated which of
course
there was nothing to incriminate him
into because he wasn't involved
uh and i had cs goal i was saying we'll
look at it and
we'll cooperate despite the evidence his
first report was categorically denied
and ignored i mean it's just shazam
being shazam like
i don't know why sam treats everything
like a conspiracy
i don't understand why shazam does this
[ __ ] he's always like
starting up drama like i don't get it
all right
so we got we got confirmation from i buy
powerdazed and
shazam um that
none of it's true it's all [ __ ] the
article from richard lewis
is kind of based off theory and not off
fact
skadoodle and i by power continued to
compete while rumors hot takes and
speculation built in the background
lewis eventually published a second
expose this time backed up by evidence
in the form of text messages
between one of the brokers and his
girlfriend he presented this evidence to
valve and on january 26 2015
more than a year after the match in
question valve
dished out its verdict we have some
interesting information
info it looks as though some pro players
have been banned by volvo
we will be directing our cs go event
partners to not allow any of the
following individuals participation
in any capacity in valve sponsored
events
could deborn casey foster dazed swag
azk steel r i p
ladies and gentlemen all i wanted to
expose i wanted to create this
honest environment i had no idea the
penalties would be this
severe but you know i'm pretty sure if
they'd confessed to it back in august
they would have they would have received
much lighter
sentences if you like to use that word
valve had decided that skadoodle and the
rest of the eye by power roster
unequivocally through the match their
punishment
the entire ibuypower team were banned
indefinitely
for all valve sponsored events except
for skadoodle
careers were cut short and the community
was justifiably shaken
it's such a shitty situation because
it's like
[Music]
there's two sides every story obviously
you know what i mean so it sucks when
you see that but
like regardless of all the positive
things there's the negative where
what they did was wrong and you had to
pay a price you made a choice
and that's what happens when you make a
choice like that
it's all done steel and days are
probably like
easily top five like best track callers
so it's definitely a setback those two
are [ __ ]
really important and then swag and azk
also i think the permabed is [ __ ]
heartbreaking man
these guys have put in for the past year
they
have been playing with the notion that
hopefully at the end of the event of the
year they'll be unbanned and
they'll be able to compete again now
here's where things get tricky
with skadoodle yes he participated in
the netcode guides match
but he was the lone player saved from an
indefinite ban from valve sponsored
events
why after looking at the cs go lounge
transactions valve determined that
skadoodle
never accepted the skins i legitimately
have no
i no real idea of why he wasn't banned i
heard the same rumors as everyone else
i've never really dived too deep into it
with those
those players who were part of that
as far as i know in this scenario that
skadoodle didn't accept any skins and
and i mean that was the big thing that
was the big evidence the smoking gun
that valve used to justify the other
bands
um and without it i guess they just
assumed that school wouldn't be in on it
i i have no idea
um and that's the story that i've been
told by all of them was that skoodle was
the
was the only vocal one who stepped up
and then kind of said you know i don't
want to do this
as far as i i'm aware
they didn't have the skins to give scott
initially and when they finally
got them and this is after the new story
broke he's just like nah
so there's no transfer valve couldn't
track it and and he got out scot-free
but i'm not sure like i i don't know
specifically what happened with the
whole skadoodle thing
that's what i heard from adk that's what
i heard
because all of us were a part of it all
of us agreed to it and all of us [ __ ]
contributed to it and that's it it's
never been confirmed exactly what
happened and
he's never made a statement on the
matter in the end i bypower were burnt
to the ground
and skadoodle found himself teamless
again
[Music]
after eye by power's implosion skadoodle
took a few months to figure out his next
move
he made a few appearances with different
rosters that never stuck
and there were even rumors of him
joining a super team alongside hiko
mikelele rayne and scream but once those
conversations fell apart skadoodle
decided to join the only remaining
contender in north america
jumping on top of liege goes big up to
nothing but skadoodle flicking onto one
gonna stop the bomb carrier with a
double can he get the triple he's
looking for this peak
gets the flick out of nitro can you get
the quad he flicks down are you kidding
me
skadoodle he's so nuts he's absolutely
insane he's at a whole
other level than anyone any other opera
in north america right now that's
unbelievable
that's just absolutely insane skadoodle
replaced shazam as the team's offer
joining the likes of sean guerrez
nothing freakazoid
and shroud as the igl shanger has
understood how to utilize skadoodle's
skill set
he understood that skadoodle was passive
calculated
and clutch as hell skadoodle was never
going to roam the map looking for frags
or force a play off an impromptu
decision
but if his team implemented the right
strategy and skadoodle got into the
right position
he could dominate a round bomb plant
committed nitro jumps over actually i
believe he saw him
we'll throw on an aid incendiary comes
in two full blind skadoodle can't too
much in this position
get a molly he's gotta get these flicks
he's gonna be so quick
he's in a back officer's lung tunnel
someone comes into the site he's spotted
the head he's one of the cap of nitro
he's gonna get mollied
forced to change up his position here in
the smoke he's trying to go for no scope
onto a dread he gets it
oh my what a hold what a flick gets
nitro as well
and skiddle is just unbelievable he's
such an amazing player with that awp the
movement on top of it to cap it all off
the movement throughout that round is
just so beautiful and
oh god schedule your master right now
and beneath that quiet exterior and
lethal gameplay
was a midwest kid who was quick with a
line and could surprisingly
lay down a beat
they call him tyler latham and he likes
to eat bacon even if he's chills
assalamu alaikum
that's not how you say it because i am
not jewish it doesn't matter
this is ruined damn that [ __ ] was dope
he's he's very humble he is very
quiet um but he is he's actually
hilarious he's actually like a really
funny guy in his sense of humor
especially when you add it into the fact
that you know it's it's being a quiet
person it's obviously going to come off
as very dry
and you know his delivery of a line in
the right moment was always was always
on point
in june of 2015 skadoodle hit a hot
streak the likes of north american
counter-strike
rarely gets to witness his transitions
from holding angles to all-out slugfest
during high-intensity clutch plays
put him in the conversation as one of
the best operas in the world
in team mate as the push begins gets the
first flight onto flame he's gonna be
flashed off lots of counter flashes
coming in from the ct's edward of great
crossfire they're gonna take out sean
gears as he comes out the drop zone
looking for another frag but
it will still on point there's a third
franchise looking for a fourth two
cts remain for him to find down two's
good doodle to clutch he needs to ace
this round repositioning now taking down
steve's just zeus remaining with eight
hp
going for the glock he must know he's
tagged and he's gonna find the ace for
his team
wow skadoodle again this guy doesn't
cease to deliver
caught a glimpse there he did saw doodle
will manage to land the shot at nothing
and now schedule
the 201 but he manages to challenge
happy gets the bomb plants in there
smith is making the rotate but he is
smoked off
screw with his up this is where he
shines he's going to peek out so almost
found it there it is skadoodle wins it
one versus can you make the one versus
five actually happened i really don't
think so
there it is oh here's the wallbangs he's
got the actual wall bang there
from yard that is glorious they had gone
for a force by
and they are going to be blasting
through onto b-side skadoodle guess what
gets two that's the bomb carrier down
gets inside for triple
just piling them down switches across
got the tag on to him there
puts jw on just one hit point shroud
does find one free kazoo comes around
and the skadoodle show is kicking off
here ladies and gentlemen
but there was one small problem three
times cloud9 made it to a finals
and three times they came up empty
skadoodle was considered to be one of
the best operas in the world but for
some reason
on the game's biggest stage na's best
team
couldn't get it done and things didn't
get much better after that
trying to get something done here but
the smoke blocking them off in upper
dark this is burning valuable time they
don't have a kit on cloud9 they have to
hit the shots of their lifetimes but
it's not going to happen michaelis takes
out one freaking's right there to take
out dennis but it is not
meant to be 1613 cloud9 denied
alu exists and freiburg peak comes out
from shore and he does tack up aloo
perfectly
he's not going down without a fight here
30 seconds he's got the bomb he's taken
down aloe
now he's gonna find one more but it
doesn't look good and there we have it
surely he's gonna walk out and find at
least one here cloud nine they're not
gonna hear them coming they're too
distracted they're too preoccupied
trying to get toward the site and it's
russia that they run into again
it's all said and done two straight maps
fanatic they'll move into the quarter
final
and cloud nine unfortunately north
america they're bowing out here yet
again
adding to cloud nine's woes was sean
gary's sudden departure from the roster
i left cot9 for like a lot of reasons i
felt like we
plateaued a little bit people weren't
into it as much as they once were
the desire to win wasn't that strong i'm
not saying it wasn't there
and it definitely is there now they're
still really good friends of mine
it's just i think a move that both both
parties needed to make
unfocused frustrated and lacking a
dedicated igl
skadoodle would finish 2015 with a great
record on paper
but playing for a team that lacked
direction it was clear
that something needed to change
that first spark of change came at the
beginning of 2016.
when cloud9 announced they had signed
one of north america's most promising
young players
in stewie2k with stewie in the mix
cloud9's big test
came at mlg columbus it didn't
go well so we do get that man advantage
now for navi they have the gear
advantage as well and caesar's just
going to
straight up take that fight with nothing
win it hands down edward is roasting and
he gets dropped down to six hp
but it's still a massive advantage here
for navi going into the retake and it's
all on shroud and it's just not meant to
be
navi will be winning their first match
in this group and cloud9
despite their best efforts they will not
make it to 10 rounds but it's got to go
they have to go right now there's a kit
only on shroud smith's tearing it down
it's going to be rpk with stewie
it's all on shroud one versus four and
g2
they'll do one better than envy no less
but it's cloud9 once more that get
completely dismantled in a major
following their lackluster finish cloud9
underwent a number of different roster
changes
freakazoid left the team in april and
was replaced by slemmy
by august slemmy stepped down and was
replaced by automatic
during that time skadoodle began to
develop a reputation for being streaky
playing incredibly well before dropping
off months at a time
he had like this three-month or this
two-month stretch where
he was being he was in the conversation
for the best hopper in the world
and and then after that it was kind of
this drop-off and then he had another
peak later on in his career and there
was a pretty extended drop-off
um and like any player you go through
waves of motivation and everything which
i would assume is what happened there
but
you know when you look at someone like
skadoodle who is so good and this also
happened to to shroud as well as
teammate
is when when people are so good um for a
stretch of time and then they just kind
of lose that
and then they become almost like
liabilities which let's be honest during
stretches of a square scootal
was a little bit of a liability um
that's just kind of the
the environment that you know schedule
kind of made for himself by how talented
he was
after a year full of mediocre and
inconsistent play the final two pieces
of skadoodle's original roster
would leave cloud9 it was officially the
end of an era
heading into 2017's denver dreamhack
open
skadoodle found himself in a new
position within the team
with the additions of tarik and rush he
was now the veteran presence on an
entirely new roster
competing on a whole nother level he's
gonna try to move towards it
automatically misses the shot he's now
low at 19 hp
legend holds on gets that kill stewie
comes back in though and trades it
so we're in a 1v1 potentially to decide
the tournament
ladies and gentlemen it's cloud9 and
take it in map number two
16-6 is the final score and with a 2-0
victory
they are the dream hack astral open
denver
champions jks might be able to change
this one but no
skadoodle hits a shot and has a only man
to trade but it's not enough it's a
double hop up for renegades and
skadoodle he'll make it work
nifty dead as well that's it cloud9
ladies and gentlemen we'll be your
victors here at the eye by power masters
2017
what a ridiculous performance in that
final map after a string of top five
finishes cloud9 rolled into the boston
major
with momentum and the feeling that maybe
just
maybe they could pull off the impossible
i mean
you know end of 2017 we started to see
the better things out of cloud9 and you
start to see some positive signs
and you start to see a team that's kind
of figuring out what they're good at but
still doesn't feel like you know a
world-beating team in any sense like
they're going to be able to go into
these series against top european squads
and be able to take them out
sure they don't look like they're going
to go to the top ever but they're like
one of the few teams that i actually
appreciate in as much as they do take
care of the teams that are below them
all the teams below the rankings you
could usually put your money that cloud9
will beat them but then they'll lose to
the ones above
it's rare you get consistent teams like
that actually but 2018
was the year of the underdog and cloud9
were looking to do what no other north
american cs go team
had ever done before the new challenger
stage went smoothly and cloud9 looked
poised to make an easy run to the
playoffs
but things got rockier in the new legend
stage
kenny's gotten stewie it's just left one
versus three
should be planted out and open plan of
that quiet game for skadoodle by the way
six kills
against this unlikely based on that stat
line but it would be the best thing he's
done
all game flashed off in the open
completely wrecked as well g2
16-8 to defeat this push there is the
peak there's the flashback very
important outcome santorus gets nothing
down to pass picks rush out the air now
another one from paz what else could he
oh my goodness
fought from him absolutely unbelievable
there from him oh my god the ace
to take the match all the hard work the
motivation and the focus that skadoodle
put on display over the last three
months
was about to be wiped away yet again but
staring down elimination skadoodle and
cloud9 dug deep and proceeded to win
three straight elimination matches two
versus four snacks and pasha
doing all they can no weapon for them to
collect plays through the smoke
automatic
hearing them executing snacks and
there's the last player pasha in the red
there he goes so they put themselves in
a position where they can get some
information they can quickly rotate to
each bomb site
both of them with eyes on a sorry
grandma oh they spotted him they
definitely knew and there's the kill
16-6
he could do this but he's got no kit no
nades and he's got to find two kills
which are
plenty polar opposites yeah entirely
again though the hp jumps across rush
nails it's 16.
for cloud nine and one final legend
status spot for skadoodle cloud nine
into the top eight
not to mention they came back from zero
and two so it looks like the curse would
continue as well
skadoodle and cloud9 regrouped picked
their shots and fought their way
to the playoffs in the quarterfinals
they once again squared off against g2
let's see if they can make this a
execute work g2 there
with their backs against the wall
running right in stewie getting the
spray down
and rushed there to pick it up there's
no chance here for the french
cloud nine two kills away from picking
up the first map and
with absolute style they shut down
shakzi
16-8 in favor of cloud9 here map number
one of the quarter-finals
and they're trying to make their way
closer scott missing the shot oh
my god very close right now that smoke
is timely
make sure they don't easily get shut
down nbk is gone and skadoodle is just
he's really feeling it right now which
was one of the key points made oh
running through the smoke
almost went down himself there's body
picking it up and now it's a one versus
one
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in there and stewie picking
up that kill
and cloud9 with the semi finals oh my
god what a story they shut down g2
almost flawlessly they followed that up
with a close 2-1 win against sk gaming
in the semi-finals
now all they had to do was take down the
european super team
that many had predicted to win the
entire tournament this
is the final boss this is the phase
roster
just look at this talent it is so
stacked
i think the problem here is the fact
that you know faze not only
won the last three encounters in the
best of three two anno it's in such a
dominant fashion as you guys could see
only
double digits two times cloud9 is
playing super well but
faze is the favorite here and they're
going to play like it
despite skadoodle racking up 27 kills
faze clan was able to squeak out a 16-14
win on mirage on overpass skadoodle and
faze's superstar opera guardian went
back and forth
trading kill for kill before cloud9 took
the map 16-10.
exploit his plays through the smoke
though undiscovered
where's the reef rag olive meister not
close enough to deal the damage
and automatic can reset the situation is
tarik waits patiently
that is phenomenal clown nine make it
work
map
it would all come down to a third map of
inferno
skadoodle was on fire reminding faze
clan and the entire world that sleeping
on one of na's premier players
was a mistake you didn't want to make i
think they may slack a play they may
sacrifice one here come the grenades
towards the bench position and they
charge let's go doodle
with the 3k it's really big issue the
spray can't be found there by brandon
gets one
all the flights are looking to defend
traded up trace left right and center
guardian
can he find the player and pit this is
massive no skadoodle gets it done
are they going to play against the clock
uh because there's 18 seconds
the bomb goes down again it's got to be
collected but there are so many cgs
running around
someone's going to collect the bomb and
plant it it's pre-collected turret takes
one in the face
carrigan gets punctured as well skeleton
must hold the line it could be two
one two left one to the right five mr
timing's right frankenstein alive
in the red he's dead it's the play offer
in fact maybe tara
is gonna go for a report five place very
close skadoodle looking to go for the
peak
hits the first shot rush covering from
pitt as well doing a great job as they
fall further back into the site
cloud9's defense is looking very strong
indeed
press back at it again from the pit
position and it doesn't
seem like there's a way to stop
cloudline now
but down 1815 with match point in sight
for cloud nine
faze clan would fight back to bring it
within one
taken out two on two now and it's taric
he's got higher health but it's not
perfect
down he goes it's guardian he's the only
man standing between cloud9
and the major it's gonna be a double
piece there's the first one
we're going to overtime number two
cloud9 don't do it they're still in this
space of faith clan
the dream of winning north america's
first ever major was just within reach
he's going to have to move forward
skadoodle repositioning after the first
frag
it's both now from quad here for phase
can cloudline close it skadoodle gets
one skadoodle can't get the third it's
nico with 12.
it's their time though is their time i'm
not sure if there is going to be a close
one
and he's done it in the corner with the
awp do they realize this i think he's
been spotted now
guys have a throat to play with he can
delay them if he can occupy their
attention long enough his teammates
can make the play just by staying there
he's a threat
oh my goodness
my god do you know what that noise means
that
it means it's match point cloud nine do
they have enough to take
over the line this time are there
flashes there will they push they'll
re-aggress
down just for the fighter guards didn't
remain automatically pushing through
it's guardian versus two can he do it
again he's in this position before to
win phase
around a very important very crucial one
can he deny cloud nine
we saw from this position before he
cannot
miss a single shot guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
all this happened they made it work
clown nine are your alien major
champions
they weren't the favorites they were the
underdogs they were a heavy underdog
but they did it for north america
skadoodles won the major
six years after starting his
counter-strike career skadoodle brought
north america
its first ever major championship and in
a case of perfect timing at the pinnacle
of his career
we got a glimpse at the midwest kid with
a heart of gold
thank you thank you i don't really have
much words to say
as you know i'm not crying you're crying
stop
uh yeah i mean not much to say i i can't
really say too much i'm just super proud
of the boys
and uh as a first major playoff you know
appearance it's um
it's amazing sorry
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
and uh thank you for all the fans who
showed up
[Applause]
[Music]
after boston skadoodle's play dropped
off again and it seemed like it was only
a matter of time before he'd either step
away
or was benched but chaos hit cloud9 as
stewie2k left the team on the same day
skadoodle decided to step back
and take time for himself he wanted out
um
i'm pretty sure at least wanted to take
some kind of a break and the
announcement was made
but then you had stewie leave and then
skadoodle is just there and he knows he
can't just leave them high and dry and
he sticks around even though he's not
motivated even though
they probably should have you know
gotten gone at a faster pace to pick
someone up to replace him
you know he's still just like i i can't
do anything else until these guys have
this figured out i can't leave them
behind i can't just you know let them
let them struggle to this degree
skadoodle could have opted for an early
beginning to the streaming career he'd
pursue later on
but he stayed opting to support the
organization that he had spent most of
his professional life with
and when skadoodle did decide to retire
from competitive counter-strike
in october of 2018 he transitioned into
a full-time streaming career
alongside former teammate and friend
shroud
are you gonna just try to brush that
deep thigh
come on
nice
[Music]
fly dude
while skadoodle is still quiet on stream
it doesn't stop his thousands of fans
from tuning in to catch glimpses of the
goofball charm we saw
on rare occasions throughout his career
but the legacy skadoodle leaves behind
is a complicated one i think his legacy
unfortunately is going to be a bit of a
rough one of of opportunities
you know for me he goes down as one of
the best players north america has ever
produced the best offer
easily that north america has ever ever
produced
the biggest headline is going to be he
brought the very first major trophy
to north america um and i mean
he remember scootaloo for five years
leading up to that major
had been part of every best team that
north america had ever had
he was he was the one constant in all of
those rosters on the eye by power lineup
that was really talented
on the cloud nine rosters that in all of
them despite sean leaving despite jordan
leaving you know he was on all the top
rosters so he brings that first major
trophy
he's the mvp of those finals in boston i
think there is something kind of
really cool about the fact that finally
overcoming some of the flaws that he'd
had for about a year
to win that major i think that's a
really really impressive story in
skoodle's kind of long tenure
with a streaky reputation and a fan base
that rooted for him at every turn
skadoodle is undoubtedly one of the
greatest players north america has ever
produced but when motivated and focused
there are few players in counter-strike
storied history
that could match him
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button